[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segment the little Cuban boy whose
mother died bringing him to America and
was later taken by force back to the
communist nation with the help of the US
government his name Elian Gonzalez he
now is a grown man but many will always
remember him as a symbol and a
frightened little boy in a famous
picture I covered it back then
tonight correspondent Steve Harrigan has
the story from Miami Thanksgiving 1999
notto Dalrymple was fishing for
mahi-mahi and heavy surf then three
miles off the coast of Fort Lauderdale I
wasn't really thinking about fishing I
was over there looking at that inner
tube and as I seen my cousin pulling in
the fish I seen a hand move on that
inner tube the hand belonged to Elian
Gonzalez tied to an inner tube by his
mother perhaps her last act before
perishing with ten others trying to
escape communist Cuba across the
shark-infested Florida Straits a Leon's
father Juan Miguel Gonzalez still in
Cuba asked for the boy back but Miami
relatives including two great uncles
refused to send elyon back the
dictatorship his mother died trying to
escape was the ultimate sacrifice of a
mother who wanted a better future of
freedom for her son and so it was
something that obviously tugged on
everybody's heart the custody battle
electrified Cubans on both sides
Miami's Little Havana around-the-clock
vigils were held around the Gonzales
family home the stalemate involving this
little boy could possibly throw new
immigration talks into jeopardy
while in Havana Cuba Fidel Castro led
daily protests demanding the boys return
to his father the international drama
dragged on for seven months until the
Clinton administration sent immigration
agents armed for battle into the home
the fishermen who saved the boy now had
him snatched from his arms Castro made
quick use of his victory elion father a
waiter who's named a member of Cuba's
National Assembly Elyon joined the young
Communist union and became an engineer
at a state-run factory in minora 18
years later Fidel is gone from the scene
the US Embassy in Havana is open for
business
but the Elyon case put a spotlight on
the bitterness and his divided Cuban
families and remains to this day
I couldn't imagine something so
beautiful could turn so ugly quick
Dalrymple has never again seen the boy
he's saved and lost in Miami Steve
Harrigan Fox News